here to react is former acting dhs
deputy secretary ken cuccinelli ken
welcome this morning so i this is what i
think is happening is the bidens want to
upgrade the beach house and have this
done by taxpayer payers right but even
i'm surprised that they are you know
don't see this even from a political
point of view as a bad move as he's
saying we can't secure the border with
walls
well to the extent they do they don't
care um i mean
this the border policies of this
administration are opposed by ordinary
democrats and they have been
since about march of 2021 literally
within a couple of months of the
president assuming this office
and so it's no surprise that they're
tone deaf
um intentionally
to the hypocrisy
of this situation and look this
secret service obviously was in dhs
they know what they're doing to
accomplish their job and and to protect
the president and the others that
they're responsible for
and they think walt's work and the
president is going along with it um it's
just more evidence that the president
while he may think well's work as well
is intentionally
avoiding accomplishing the mission of
securing the border with deadly
consequences
not just along the border but across
america yeah you know i'd say one of the
most depressing things i saw when i went
to the border was the piles of wall just
rusting
next to
a detention center that was fortified
like fort knox so it was just crazy to
me like i i couldn't make sense of it
and it just made me so sad to see um all
those walls people flowing across the
border and then they use walls for their
homes and for the migrants when they
come over um you mentioned how deadly it
is um and so just this week our law
enforcement caught migrants wearing
special suits to blend into the desert
this as the d.a commissioner warns that
mexican cartels are killing americans
with fentanyl at catastrophic and record
rates can this weekend is going to be
fentanyl overdose
awareness
day i think tomorrow indeed so what are
your thoughts on that
well look even with record seizures at
the border ask your
local street cops what's the street
price of fentanyl
of heroin of cocaine
every single hard killing drug
in america comes over that southwestern
border now the only one the cartels
aren't uh manufacturing themselves on an
industrial scale is cocaine which is
coming from south america and it's all
routed through mexico they literally
control the entire hard drug
uh trade and it's one of the purest
forms of supply and demand and the
answer to the street price question is
off the charts low
and what that means is they're getting
these drugs across the border nearly at
will and that's why you're seeing the
death rate for overdoses and bad drugs
by the way as well
it's going through the roof and this is
why every town is a border town we are
all affected by this crisis yeah i don't
know if you could see the the b-roll
that we were showing the footage we were
showing some of it looking like it's
delicious candy um it's really dangerous
stuff not to mention ken as you well
know we are destabilizing mexico and
we're starting to see signs of the power
of the cartel and how it is impacting on
the other side of the border um we could
have a failed state um in in not a long
time from now because the cartels are
more and more powerful every day
yeah strategically if you think of the
history of mexico they have never had
full control of their entire country
they're very proud people with very good
reason but they've never had full
control their country and the cartels
are running a good portion of it to the
detriment of the united states of
america they're running our border and
now they're going to be running mexico
full with without impunity uh ken
cuccinelli thank you so much for joining
us this morning appreciate your insights
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis